Oh,
Richard Branson.
Well,
is there anything,
he doesn't do high school dropouts at the age of 16 he started companies.
He's seen the wells and he has more adventures than anyone could dream of in a
lifetime.
He's a creative personality and a brilliant businessmen as well as being an
energetic charitable man who has built a brand,
a recognizable around the world.
I Adams,
by the way,
he's also worth nearly $5 billion.
So how exactly did Branson gets to where he is today?
Let's start at the beginning of the 1950s in,
sorry.
England's Branson was born at the eldest son of Edward and Eve Branson,
a lawyer and a flight attendance.
Though she was a flight attendant,
Eve Branson didn't sit idly by on their days off.
She built a wooden trash cans and tissue boxes selling them for extra money for
the family.
Watching his mother's success builds Branson's admiration for entrepreneurs and
gave them an option for when school just wasn't working out.
She was always supportive of him and was even known to tell people he would one
day be prime minister of England.
His mother was also an influence on Branson's active minds and his lifestyle
that have become so much a part of his international brand today.
She didn't let her children watch TV.
Instead of pushing her son and two daughters outside to entertain themselves and
make themselves useful though clearly brilliant.
Branson was not a successful students who have dyslexia and growing up school.
That was difficult for him,
but this Lexia did not stop him and now he credits it as a key part of his
formula for success.
If you have a learning disability,
you become a very good delegator because you know what your weaknesses are and
you know what your strengths are and you make sure that you find great people to
step in and deal with your weaknesses.
He moved through several schools as a child,
eventually giving up on institutionalized learning at the age of 16 but he did
not give up on achieving.
When he dropped out of school,
he already knew that being an entrepreneur that was the right life for him.
He started out with an idea and it's with an ultimate goal far beyond just
earning money.
From my very first day as an entrepreneur,
I felt the only mission worth pursuing in business is to make people's lives
better.
His first venture as a teenage businessmen who was publishing a magazine called
students.
I took me 16 years old with no input or work for anyone but students.
Ranson was able to secure $8,000 in advertising for the magazines.
First issue,
this was 1966 and $8,000 was a lot more money them so much in fact that Branson
didn't even have to sell the first issue.
Instead,
he gave away 50,000 copies,
building the brand's name,
Andy,
potentially loyal customer base for future issues.
It was the first demonstration of a brilliant business mind with an utterly
impressive talent for marketing students.
It continued in its original form for three years,
but in 1969 Branson,
he felt the urge to make it even bigger and to take it in a new direction.
Advertisements for records were a large part of the magazine's revenue,
so Branson took records and the magazine and put them together.
Essentially,
he spotted a gap in the market for mail order record.
Sales,
his man order business when it was Christians with a name that we all know today
and that would be virgin,
but it wasn't actually Richard Branson who came up with that name.
It was one of his first employees.
Though they were successful,
the name was perfect for the company.
As all of the young people involved in this,
when you to business,
well that name,
it obviously stuck and to now it's come to wrap present much more than just mail
order music though the mail order business.
It was popular,
it wasn't making enough money to stay afloat and Branson when he needed cash,
he decided that the best way to do that was avoided giving the government of the
entire share of the taxes that he actually owed.
You cannot with a scheme through which he avoided reporting all of the records
that were sold in the UK falsifying the numbers of those that were exported.
It sounded good and it did bring in cash birth.
Well it was discovered and we actually ended up in jail and having to pay over
$60,000 in fines.
This obstacle and a short time in jail didn't slow him or his business ambitions
down though,
even with the tax fraud scandal,
it was only less than two years after starting the man or the record business
that Branson was able to take yet another leap in 1971 he opens an actual bricks
and mortar store in order to sell records.
Then it was only a year before he bought himself a high in and was able to build
a recording studio in [inaudible].
Now that he had a studio,
the next logical step,
it was to start a record label.
So he looked around and ended up signing an artist he thought would be okay,
but not likely to have overwhelming success as no one else would take him on.
And so what was the name of this newly created record label?
But of course it was a virgin records.
The label had success almost immediately with its first artist,
Mike Oldfield staying on the chance with the album tubular bells for nearly five
years.
To put this in perspective.
The record was on the charts as along as it took from Branson to go from selling
records by mail to having his own record label.
The success of Oldfield and Branson under the upstart virgin ladle bit didn't go
unnoticed far from it.
Huge names like the sex pistols,
the rolling stones culture club,
Janet Jackson and Genesis.
They were all later signed onto the label.
Yeah,
drown the 1970s while Bronson was in his twenties he focused on his ever-growing
music business,
but by 1984 he was again itching to try something new,
so he took what seems like a pretty large jump across industries.
He invested in a new airline business before launching the full fledged airline
service.
Branson had realized the potential for doing so when his own flights to the
British Virgin Islands was canceled being wealthy.
They didn't have to wait around.
There's an APP or for the next flight at the whim of the airlines,
he could charter his own plane.
So he did it,
but he didn't keep the launch plan to himself.
Instead,
he charged the others.
He was supposed to be on his original flight to the British Virgin Islands,
a smaller fee and they all flew together on a chartered plane down to the island
is creative minds and business intuition.
They saw an opportunity here and Branson,
well he was ready to seize it.
Soon after his initial experimental charter flight to the British Virgin
Islands,
he called up Boeing and ask what they had for sale while they said that they had
a Boeing seven four seven available lands,
Branson bought it and this was the start of his fleet of airplanes as he has
with the man or to record business.
Branson's saw a need and a way that he could run a business better than others
who were currently doing so.
So Entry Richard Branson style.
They did just that.
We just made it that much more special than the other airlines we were competing
with.
He says of what he achieved with Virgin Atlantic Airways.
Long before it was the norm,
virgin was offering such luxuries as individual TV screens to help people pass
the time on flights.
Now.
Initially virgin it operates is only out of London's Gatwick Airport,
but by 1991 it had grown to the point where it was given permission to fly out
of Heathrow British Airways.
Well,
they were not say pleased by this new threats to their previously unchallenged
supremacy and they certainly did not sit idly by while virgin kept gobbling off
the market show.
In 1993 virgin is accused of British Airways of he's so cool.
Series of dirty tricks that ranged from computer hacking to reliable following
the accusations,
British Airways,
they settled over at nearly $4 million in legal fees and compensation.
Now you might be wondering,
well,
what did Branson do with the money that he received in the settlements?
Well,
he didn't just stick it all in his own bank accounts.
Instead he decided to share it with virgin is employees now they the settlement.
It was a win for the company.
It didn't mean virgin and Branson were completely successful and just had
nothing to worry about us.
On the contrary,
in fact,
Branson was unfortunately forced to sell his music business in order to keep his
empire going.
Emi.
They bought virgin records in 1992 and although it was a good business decision,
it was a tough personal choice for Branson.
The music business,
it was Branson's baby,
it was his first venture and he was the reason everything else he had built was
possible.
Over the years,
he's been very open about just how difficult that sale was for him.
I mean,
you build something from scratch.
We had just signed Janet Jackson,
we had signed the rolling stones when we sold it and I remember running down
Ladbroke grove tears streaming down my face with a check for $1 billion.
Since the sale,
Virgin Airlines has continued to grow brands,
so now today,
cell phone sector to his business and then a space travel venture called a
virgin galactic.
500 people have bought tickets,
have an as yet unscheduled flight into space with Virgin Galactic.
Overall,
Richard Branson owns 200 companies linked to the virgin brands,
but well business,
it's not his only interest and nor is it his own
Branson.
He could just sit comfortably in his island,
resort home.
That's well,
he prefers to explore all corners of the welds and to do so in ways far more
interesting and it's far more powerless than in the comfort of a Virgin Atlantic
plane.
He's flashy than your average billionaire with no qualms about risking his life
and the pursuit of adventure adventure that also serves double duty as he can
beat the out of the box marketing strategy.
He makes no distinction between his professional lens,
personal endeavors,
simply aiming to enjoy life and it's making a difference where he can.
I don't think of work as work and to play as play.
It's all living well.
In 1985 Richard Branson made international news when he tried to set a world
record for the fastest crossing of the Atlantic.
They failed in totally spectacular fashion as his boat capsized and he had to be
rescued by eight British military helicopter.
Is that of this?
Do not be embarrassed by your failures.
Learn from them and start again as well.
Again in Branson's true form here,
absolutely.
Desk.
In 1986 he attempted to the Atlantic crossing again,
but this time he succeeded in spectacular fashion.
He broke the world record for the crossing by over two hours.
But breaking this record,
well,
it wasn't enough for Branson.
He wanted more adventure and he also wants to keep his name and the virgin his
name in the news.
It doesn't a water crossing,
but now we wanted to move on to our airplanes.
They were not exciting enough,
so we opted to cross the Atlantic in a hot air balloon and then,
I mean crossing the Atlantic,
it wasn't enough.
So he decided to cross the Pacific in a hot air balloon.
Now it wasn't all purely for the pursuit of adventure that he took on these hot
air balloon challenges actually truly enjoy traveling by hot air balloon.
He says,
my favorite mode of transport is hot air ballooning.
It's so graceful to be blown by the winds to go where the wind takes you.
Now the balloon Branson took on his first flight.
It was a record breaker in and of itself.
It was the size of a 21 looks story building and it was built to fly to speed of
over 200 miles per hour.
It was simply the largest and the fastest balloon ever constructed,
large and vast.
They didn't make that balloon immune from danger.
The flights path was from the state of Maine to islands as when the balloon
reached islands.
It didn't attach as it was supposed to.
Instead,
Branson and his crew found themselves dipping into the freezing waters of the
Atlantic.
His crew jumped out of the balloon,
but Branson was forced to stay put after the balloon rapidly lifted to 12,000
feet with him still in us terrified,
but able to remain calm.
Ranson navigated the balloon back down towards the water and jumped into the
ocean.
When he saw her,
he was just a few dozen feet above its surface and now let's move on to the
Pacific blue trip because this wasn't much calmer.
They ran out of most of their fuel partway through and they were dependent on
the jet stream to simply push them forward.
Branson said,
I was facing almost certain death we could have just slumped on the floor and
accepted our face or try to fly the balloon into the core of the jet stream and
finds the strongest winds you can find.
Stay awake for three days and do everything you can to avoid what on paper looks
like a sad ending Branson's crew.
Well,
they chose to stay away.
You can do what they could and as they overcame that challenge,
they didn't break the records they hope to,
but they did live to tell the town of their adventure and that was all they
could have asked for it.
That,
okay,
School Amanda,
like Branson who devotes much of his life to the pursuit of pleasure,
rent growing your business might seem to be pretty full up on time commitments,
but for Branson,
business and success,
it's about much more than just amassing wealth.
It's about helping people.
I never started out in business to make money.
I wanted to create products that made a difference in people's lives.
The same is true today in my opinion.
There's nothing quite like the gift of giving.
When you see firsthand the impacts it can have,
it becomes the best feeling in the world.
Branson has used not only his money,
but his brands in his new sobriety to influence world leaders.
He and Peter Gabriel of the virgin records span genesis talk to Nelson Mandela
or about their dream of having a group of world leaders for them to work on the
pressing issues facing the people of the world.
What,
what was the result of that?
Well,
that would be the group,
the elders,
a group of some of the world's most respected former leaders,
including UN officials,
president Jimmy Carter and Desmond Tutu,
Branson.
He does provide funding for the group and its initiatives,
but it was really his initial idea and his willingness to Karen's have those
initial conversations that really made this all possible.
And then we come to environmental issues,
which are one of Branson's personal passions.
He's committed to hundreds of millions of pounds to fighting global warming and
to even hosted a summit at his private island in 2009 they might have the
question,
why does Richard Branson care about preserving the earth and its beauty quite
some much?
Well,
like as creative beds,
Branson credits his childhood home and the amount of time he spent playing
outside of this.
I was fortunate to have been brought up in the countryside in a little cottage.
I suppose that the first 10 years of my life were spent in the countryside,
biking,
climbing trees,
and didn't touch with nature.
I suppose that's where my enough of nature started.
Overall,
he's worked with dozens of charities in his life,
dedicating his time and his money to the causes that he cares most about.
The United Nations has even recognized his efforts,
giving him the citizen of the world award in 2007 most recently,
Branson has thrown his charitable energy towards helping the Caribbean islands
rebuild in the wake of Hurricane Irma is destruction during the fall of 2017
with his home on Necker island in the British Virgin Islands.
He has a personal interest in doing so,
but it's gone well beyond just rebuilding his own luxurious home.
He spent time helping mobilize rescue efforts and assisting with the
distribution of water and supplies,
as well as helping people find shelter.
Clearly,
Branson is not a man to stand idly by when there is a need or opportunity.
Yeah.
In promoting the virgin brands and promoting the courses he cares about.
Branson has become a highly recognizable personality and a frequent guest on
news and other shows,
but he doesn't always stick to the serious stuff he's made in the bond film.
Casino Royale and cement to displace isn't nineties icon.
When he started on both Baywatch and friends,
he was also featured in the iconic apple think different towns alongside such
luminaries as John Lennon.
Gandy Einstein and public [inaudible] Richard Branson.
He's not your typical uptake businessmen.
He's a creative luminary who was impacted all the corners of business and
impacted many parts of the world and that's what he aims to do.
Each day he wants to put the things he's passionate about to work for himself
and for the world.
A passionate belief in your business and personal objectives can make all the
difference between success and failure if you aren't proud of what you're doing.
Why should anybody else there?
Amid everything Branson,
there's also found time to marry and have children.
His first marriage was in the heyday of virgin records when he went to Kristin
to Massey in 1972 that marriage blessed him don't be seven years and the couple
of divorced in 1979 Branson had already met his second wife Templeman.
By the time he and Tom Massey divorced and his grandson admitted as much later
to piers Morgan,
he had a daughter with Templeman in 1979 sadly,
I'm Charlie lived for only four days.
It wasn't until 10 years and two more children later that Branson and Templeman
actually tied the knot.
Richard Branson.
He could have continued to struggle through high school doing things he hated
and that he didn't care about.
He could have fought his way to becoming a lawyer like his dad or settling into
a middle class office job in London or the surrounding area.
He could have stuck it out,
but he listened to his instincts and he went with his heart,
a drop house.
He could have fallen to the bottom and struggled through life,
feeling sorry for himself,
for having a learning disability,
but it's passion and his personality along with his mother's constant
encouragement propelled him forward.
Richard Branson drew on his creativity,
took risks and never shied from a challenge.
Every time he failed you brushed himself off and try it again.
He gives back to a wells that has given him much and he continues to succeed as
a businessman and as an admired personality.
Richard Branson once said that if you want to stand out from the crowd,
give people a reason not to forget you.
Richard Branson.
Well,
he clearly follows his own advice and this has led him to a successful and
passionate life.
So I really hope you enjoyed the video.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and do not forget to subscribe,
but put our brand new biographies just like this of Modern Day people like
Richard Branson or people from history.
Also some things on the darker science serial killers.
We cover the gamut of people we think would make a good buyer graphics videos.
Did you subscribed brand new videos twice a week?
That's Mondays and Thursdays.
Also,
some of our older videos over there on the right.
Most stuff that you can check out right now and as always,
thank you for watching.
Yeah.